lily what's going on i have been with my
boyfriend
for two years about two years now and we
have a one-year-old
and he is a military vet um
and i feel like i'm putting too much
pressure on him
he is struggling with ptsd and he had a
breakdown around the texas ice storm
we had a very rough few days where we
didn't know
if we were going to make it out if he
was going to be okay
um and i feel like i'm the one that's
been putting
you know that extra pressure that's
maybe taking him to that tipping point
um and i just don't know i want him to
know
he is loved by not only myself
but my son that he has
so when you say you're he has a reason
to keep going
yeah well man thank you for loving your
husband
when you when you say that you're
putting extra pressure on him and that
you're the cause of his breaking point
what do you mean
so um i'm a first-time mom
so this is my first goal round so i feel
like
you know i want the best for my son
so i want you know us to focus on
getting our first home
i want us to you know be stable
financially
i know for some time it was the vehicle
so i
my vehicle i gave to him and i wanted a
bigger vehicle for
my son so i put that extra pressure on
him
um so it's just it's been a lot like i
feel like you know
he works a lot he works very hard but
i'm you know i'm with my son 24 7.
i also work from home so i feel like
sometimes i want that extra help
yeah for sure where does your picture of
this perfect
setup for your one-year-old son come
from
so here i guess so here's what and i'll
tell you like so i'm asking the question
from this
um my wife drives a a 2010 prius that we
shove two kids into
they can't even fit cause my son's
humongous
i drive an 06 truck with 150 000 miles
on it
and they just had to be in the shop
so and we've got an old house and we've
had to rent a few houses here and there
and we've had
my kids are resilient and they love life
and they're up for wild adventures and
my son
asked the other day hey daddy no matter
what please don't ever move me again i
just want to be wherever we're at
right here right so i asked you that to
tell you i have
my son has moved more since he's 10 than
i did i think i was like 30 or something
where are you getting this picture that
we have to have this car
this house this set of furniture this
environment
or there's something is going to happen
to our kid where is that narrative
coming from
the instability i had growing up ah
okay look at you wisely come from
right we're co we both come from broken
homes yep um we both come from
instability with
and we see you know as you grow you
realize how unstable things are
and you start seeing it from a bigger
picture but when you're you're young
you don't know you only see what you
hear yeah or like what's happening at
that moment
and so a lot of it comes from that
instability that i had so i went to
multiple schools there was never
consistency it was it was a lot of
turmoil within our household
um so it was a lot and i guess that
now that i'm a mom it's like you want
everything not so much as better right
you just want that stability for your
child
and so can i tell you a significant
temptation
is to to take that sort of instability
and to find it in stuff
and when you try to find stability and
stuff
you inherently start that cycle all over
again
does that make sense what i'm saying yes
so you moved around a lot
did your parents get divorced or was
there abuse fighting in the home growing
up
uh so there was abuse there was fighting
uh there was divorce and i as soon as i
could leave my left
there you go okay so you know what
growing up you got ptsd
tube i mean ptsd two by the way okay
you're both trauma survivors
and yours is more long-term and acute
and his may be
i mean yours is more long-term and
cumulative his is a cute
yours is probably cute too you probably
saw some stuff that no little kid should
see is that fair
yes yeah and so some people escape that
with addiction some people escape that
with relationships
some people escape that with
i'll be damned this is going to look
like this
i've got a picture of something in my
head and i will make sure everything's
in
order in place because this is what
stability looks like
does that sound right yes okay
anything less than that is feels like a
slippery slope towards what you had and
unfortunately the way we have to get to
those pictures
is by complaining poking prodding
continuing to fight because those are
the only tools we have that's the only
tools you learned
and so you're trying to build a new home
with the same tools does that make sense
yes
and what's gonna happen is you're gonna
end up building the same house over
again
and what happens with veterans
especially is they learn a whole new set
of tools they get they get rebuilt with
a new set of tools right
and they have to learn how to not apply
those
sets of tools everywhere especially in
their civilian life especially in their
marriages especially in their parenting
and now you and your husband have a
dance
and as you've seen this dance doesn't
end well right
no it doesn't so before we get to him
here's what i want to challenge you to
do
i'd love for you is he a good dad oh yes
is he a good husband besides the fact
that he's a veteran with ptsd and he
does military e-things
does he love you like chris where's his
combat boots oh jeez does he wear his
combat boots to mow the yard in
shorts combat boots oh yes oh
come on guys come on i'm staring at a
veteran right now
yeah short shorts combat boots out in
the lobby he's smiling he's like yep
guilty
he does doesn't he yes and tell me that
i'm you know tell me that that man would
set the world on fire for you too
wouldn't he
yes he would somebody i i wo the day
somebody would mouth off to you in a
public place with him there right
yes i feel like it would be both of us
he he would smile on the way to jail
right
because right so hey here's the thing
here's what's beautiful
you're both coming from a place where
y'all are tethered into one another
so now it's not about hey i don't love
her it's not about i don't love him
this is about we love each other so
fierce and we keep
opening our tool bags and all we have is
like a screwdriver and a hammer
and we're trying to saw wood with a
hammer and we're trying to roof
the house with a screwdriver and all
that means is y'all just got to
double down on getting some new tools
and that's going to start with both of
you recognizing that you
come from a really traumatic childhood
that that little girl that little lily
has got to heal from
because she's going to keep standing
watch to make sure nobody gets to lily's
heart
nobody because we know what happens when
someone gets in your heart they can hurt
you
and he has seen stuff that people are
not supposed to see
and he's gonna make sure that will not
get to my wife that will not get to my
baby
and he'll see it everywhere and then all
of a sudden
the state's electric grid goes out right
and then it becomes real
right and then you saw what happens when
it becomes real
was that scary for the whole house oh
yes
yeah it was it was it's one of those
where you don't want
you don't want to expose your child to
see even as young as
a year old yeah but you know life kind
of happens and you you can't
there's no way to filter that that's
right so i want to tell you
in a used honda civic your baby's going
to be great
in a old 97 camry with 300 000 miles it
gets you where you need to go
for a couple of years while you all pay
off your debts and while you get on your
feet
financially your baby's going to be fine
you're going to be embarrassed but
you're not dating anymore anyway you got
the guy
right what do you care right and
you're gonna be great mom and your
baby's gonna have a great life
in a used uh bassinet
and with towels from walmart
and your husband's gonna need to go
through a season of of getting well
and that's hard and that starts with you
look at him in the eye and say i love
you baby
and i've put a lot of pressure on us to
accumulate stuff because i had this
perfect vision picture in my head of
what my of what life had to be
and i realized man i was trying to
squeeze squeeze
all of the joy and love and excitement
and adventure out of this family
in pursuit of something stuff
and i want you to tell them i'm gonna
you lily are gonna do the hard work of
going to meet with somebody to talk
about your childhood
and that you were gonna be the power you
made brave step powerful step number one
when you got out of that house
power powerful brave step number two is
you are gonna
face turn and face that generational
trauma you're gonna stare that forest
fire in the face
and say not my family not my baby not my
husband
and this one though you can't fight with
fists and you can't fight with guns you
got to fight it with
vulnerability humility
tears learning new skills
and for him he showed you he's
struggling your husband is he's not he's
not doing great
is he still in or has he gotten out so
he's
out um do you still y'all still have
tricare access
i'm sorry do y'all still have access to
tricare
uh no no okay no i want
but go ahead i'm sorry the
so the the i think this
the struggle that he's facing is
you know you're right the military
restructures its soldiers right you
become a soldier
yeah um and then whenever you are
deployed you know you go on your
missions you you know you do everything
that you're told to do
you're told what to do in the morning
you're told what to do in the evening
and you have
all of your days planned out and you
have some form of you you
create a family within your barracks you
know and you have to
then once everything's done you're
thanked and your throat is thrown back
into
civilian life and you don't know you
know you're not
you know it's it's like you're told
you're taught to make a bomb but you
can't put that down on your resume
right right it's like um that's that
transition so i feel like it went from
i'm a soldier i'm back to being a
civilian
i have a partner now in life and now i'm
a dad
and here's what's beautiful about that
it doesn't sound beautiful but it is
here's why he learned how to do those
things
and that means he can learn he can learn
how to experience home life and it's a
process and it's something you go
through
and there's a number of veterans
resource services there
in texas there's a number of national
veterans resource services all over the
country
there are groups that meet in the
evenings there are groups that meet in
the mornings
he learned how to go be a soldier
and he learned how to create family
inside of barracks overseas
and he learned that when he came home
he's got to do things differently
and he can learn to love you guys the
way he wants to
and the way you all deserve the same way
as you
can learn how to love to
so i want you both to commit to getting
the help that you need
either together by yourself at some
point you're gonna do this together
because you're gonna learn new skills
together
you're both coming from trauma you're
both gonna heal from trauma
and you're both gonna create a new
family legacy together
and it starts with your bravery and
vulnerability for your call lily thank
you so much
to your husband if he's listening to
this i want to thank you for your
service i want to thank you for what you
put your heart and mind through
and i want you to know that this entire
community is around you even when it
feels like we're not
and there is healing and learning on the
other side of this
lily's gonna walk with you brother and
you're gonna walk with him